you're obviously becoming more popular
in this country you're extremely popular
in england in your own country and yet
i've heard that you take public
transportation which i think is very
cool what is the quickest way to get
from a to b right yeah well good for you
but do people in in england do people
bother you when they see you and you
call them the two the two youtube they
well they do if i'm with my children
people tend not to but if i'm on my own
it can be
well people tend to come up to me and
say
you're that one aren't you
so what can you say to that i'm that one
what you know yeah um yeah yeah you've
been you you've you've been in what
films have you been in yes don't you
love it when they act they demand that
you tell them
who you are and what you've been in i
mean i made the terrible mistake of once
sort of starting to list the films um
pursuit of happiness no no that's not it
um
mission impossible too no
and so going through my entire resume i
just felt so humiliated and deflated by
the end right you're just like well you
know i i've mentioned this a million
times but i had someone come up to me
once ago yeah yeah you're that guy from
the conan o'brien show uh
like yeah yeah that's me yeah i don't
know because they you know they mean
well and they're all excited but they're
um their self-respect just seems to sort
of
disappear well there's another thing too
where sometimes i don't know you've had
where you go someplace like i'll go into
a mcdonald's or everything people say
why are you here
yes like i don't i'm not allowed like
because i like to go to mcdonald's yeah
i like the happy meal it makes me happy
okay
um now you're very well known uh among
your friends for your ingenious pranks
you like to play pranks occasionally i
do i grew up on pranks my dad was just
the the biggest prankster that was the
fun we used to have on the weekends yeah
and you uh a good friend of this show
he's been on many times one of your
co-stars simon pegg he oh he was the
most frustrating victim of my pranks i
tell you i had a whole movie with him
and i had a lot of time to wait
unfortunately in the trailer and so
while simon was on set i'd be in the
trailer sort of inventing the next prank
and i did everything from cellophane i
think you call it saran wrap
over the toilet like really like smooth
it out to make it perfect that's
disgusting
it doesn't matter it's it's the prank so
you get very excited about the prank and
i really prepare for them you know i'll
even sort of like i created a human
stool out of a
plus like king-sized mars bar and placed
that in his toilet bowl with a little
apple juice around the edge just for
authenticity you know you're just you're
just a disgusting person no listen it
was it was a prank and a snack all in
one
[Applause]
[Music]
i would look through my curtains in my
trailer and wait for simon to get off
the set come to his trailer knowing that
he's going to walk into his trailer look
into the bathroom and be appalled yeah
and so i'd wait you know the one minute
just waiting for his reaction and he'd
always come out as though nothing had
happened and i'd come rushing out of my
trailer and be like simon anything in
there
no right and that was he wouldn't give
you the satisfaction never ever ever
give him the satisfaction so we finished
the movie and about six months later it
was the we were doing the press for the
film and on a press junket the actor
sits in a hotel room and then the
different journalists come in with you
so you're there all day with the same
crew and you've got your little seat and
your water
so the night before i went to a
supermarket and bought really cheap
brand vodka and i bought some three huge
bottles of vodka so i got there early
went into simon's hotel room where he
was going to be doing his press junket
and replaced all the mineral water
bottles with vodka
and i said and i said to the crew please
just run the cameras as soon as he comes
in please and so they did so it's
actually on film they put it on the dvd
um you know the added extras so he comes
into the room he sits down someone comes
to do his powder and what you do is you
get your bottle in a water straight away
and you fill up your glass for the day
so he filled up the glass took a huge
goal at 8 30 in the morning and
immediately he hadn't seen me for six
months the first thing out of his mouth
was newton
[Music]
and it was the best honestly it was
worth it it was worth it finally you
know that prank would not work on is
andy richter
go go
[Applause]